boa tarde eu era muito pequena muito
criança quando meu pai minha mãe
perceberam que eu tinha uma habilidade
ea coordenação para dançar e minha mãe é
uma pessoa muito sensível estimulou isso
e aos seis anos de idade entrei na
escola municipal de frevo
comecei até aulas com meu grande mestre
nascimento do passo e fui me aprimorando
tecnicamente e me profissionalizando
como dançarina ainda muito nova e eu
participei de vários concursos em recife
concursos de dança e comecei a ganhar
alguns prêmios
eu ganhei o concurso de passo do recife
rainha mirim do carnaval e foi tricampeã
do festival de dança de joinville que
era o maior da américa latina na época
que comecei a dar entrevistas e aparecer
nos jornais é divulgar um programa de
rede nacional
a dança do frevo viajei recebendo
convites para trabalhar nas feiras de
internação e internacionais de turismo
no exterior
e aí fui pra vários países pelo mundo
dançando
então desde criança tinha que lidar com
a sensação de ser diferente das outras
crianças da minha idade enquanto os meus
amigos estavam estudando para a prova
estavam brincando se divertindo eu
ficava barganhando com os professores as
minhas faltas viajava porque eu ia
treinar porque eu ia participar de
festivais e essa sensação de ser
diferente também
ela se exaltava ainda na escola de frevo
porque eram escola freqüentada
principalmente por crianças e jovens
muito carentes
então eu era
a menina de classe média branquinha
filha de médica de engenheiro no
ambiente de pessoas muitos capítulos
então eu realmente tinha a sensação de
ser diferente
eu tive privilégio e sorte de ter a
estrutura afetiva e material para
desenvolver minhas habilidades
só que não tinha consciência de que eu
tenha sorte e privilégio
eu achava que o que diferenciava das
pessoas era porque eu era especial
eu escutava isso de pontos adultos neles
diziam não se você a menina prodígio
você nasceu com a estrelinha no seu
peito nasceu para brilhar e eu só vi
aquelas mensagens e começava a achar que
tudo dava certo na minha vida porque eu
era especial e contraditória mente tem
um sentimento de ser diferente
eu também tenho que lidar com um tipo de
solidão e de isolamento porque eu não me
sentia comum
isso fez com que eu comecei a perceber
que tinha alguma coisa errada e em
especial porque eu vi que as pessoas
gostavam de mim pelo que eu era
pelo que eu fazia de bom as pessoas
gostavam de mim pelo que exercia bem e
não era de verdade na intimidade mesmo
que me conhecer a minha família e na
minha adolescência teve vários atritos
com a minha irmã ela que eu diga eu era
muito egocêntrico tinha dificuldade
muito grande reconheceu o valor das
outras pessoas e eu vi que eu tenho que
lidar
eu fiquei com que lidar com duas
fileiras à tela que o mundo elogiava que
as pessoas aplaudiu estava algo de ter
pequena e aquela que era frágil e
insegura cheio de vaidades e aqui é a
vida como é
aos 14 anos eu machuquei meu joelho e
fiquei impossibilitada de dançar para os
dias 5 anos depois aos 19 o machuquei
novamente o joelho e aí eu fiquei
impossibilitado de dançar por um tempo
maior fiquei quase um ano afastada da
dança e foi um período muito difícil de
muita dor é porque eu tava tendo que
abrir mão de tudo aquilo que eu tinha
conquistado como pertencimento como
dançarina então por um ano eu não tinha
esse recurso e foi importantíssimo para
poder me enxergar de outro jeito né
quando eu voltei a dançar que eu vi que
eu podia voltar a dançar eu entrei numa
grande crise sobre a artista porque pra
mim não fazia mais sentido se é aquela
bailarina colorida que dava saltos e que
representar a cultura popular pernambuco
isso já suava meio falso
e aí eu disse que eu vou fazer com essa
dança que eu faço com esse frevo que
corpo que que vai representar agora esse
meu estado de espírito esse lugar que eu
tenho buscado e aí dentro desses
questionamentos
eu junto com a minha amiga dela maia que
dirigiu e concebeu criamos o nosso
primeiro solo ela conseguiu junto comigo
eu primeiro solo de dança que tinha como
o título uma pergunta
o frevo é teu e solo foi um divisor de
águas na minha vida porque foi a
primeira vez que eu fiz um trabalho de
dança que eu não esperava ser elogiada
eu estava me abrindo para a
possibilidade do estranhamento das
pessoas e do fracasso
eu não queria subir no palco para fazer
os pulos virtuoso
coisas que eu sabia que as pessoas já
iriam gostar eu queria realmente
investigar uma coisa que era mais em pé
que podia não ser bonita aos olhos do
grande público
e aí pra minha surpresa e só fui muito
bem recebido no festival que eu
apresentei eu recebi um convite para
apresentar ele em são paulo no instituto
brincante de rosane almeida e antônio
nóbrega
levei o trabalho pra lá e pouco tempo
depois fui chamada pra morar lá em são
paulo pra trabalhar nos projetos do
instituto
e aí foi um outro outra crise sair de
recife e para uma cidade onde não tinha
memória porque aqui eu andava na rua
algumas pessoas reconheciam a menina do
frevo a menina do frevo e lá não tem
memória por dizer que queria dizer que
meu nome era maria todo mundo acreditar
então spaulo entrei nessa crise também
sobre como lidar com a minha arte
eu precisava catuta alguns lugares
dentro de mim e aí eu entrei na terapia
e das várias sessões que eu fiz tinha
uma que eu me lembro bem foi um
exercício e terapeuta fez ele mandou
ficar na oposição à baixada assim que
era uma posição desconfortável ele me
deixou naquela posição saiu da sala eu
não entendi o qual é o objetivo da qilu
então eu fiquei resistindo aquela
posição o máximo que eu pude
alguns minutos depois ele voltou para a
sala e me viu intacta na mesma posição e
ele queria realmente trabalhar comigo
essa minha necessidade de é parece estar
confortável mesmo em situações
desconfortáveis e aí nesse dia
conversando com ele e concluiu quanto
que eu tinha me tornado refém dessa
necessidade de parecer ser boa não é
crescer no palco me tenha me dado esse
recurso e aprendi a fingir muito bem as
minhas dores né porque o dançarino
muitas vezes está com dor muscular
entrou no palco e tem que dançar ou
quando é uma coreografia em fingir que
nada aconteceu então quando caleb uma
queda de dançando tem que levantar e
continuar então eu tinha eu tinha
assimilado isso levado isso para a minha
vida também ao ponto de lembrar de uma
história que eu tinha 9
anos mesmo que gosta muito de contar
isso eu e dançando no recife antigo é
tava descalça aí falei meu pé começou a
sangrar e minha mãe viu aquilo ficou
apavorada de minha filha seus pés estão
sangrando flávio para dançar e eu na
hora respondi mãe nos preocupa que o que
importa são os aplausos
era muita pretensão da minha parte achar
que eu ia conseguir carregar tudo sempre
como se fosse um palco né e e aí é com o
tempo
depois dessa história do solo eu tenho
me encorajado realmente a fazer coisas
que que fazem de confrontar as minhas
fraquezas as minhas fragilidades e lá em
são paulo eu fiquei me questionando
descargas eu morrer amanhã eu vou ter
investido meu tempo tentando ser o
melhor de mim o que eu fiz o que eu não
fiz ainda que gostaria muito de fazer
a primeira coisa que vem à cabeça a
cantar eu amo cantar só que diferente da
dança eu não tinha facilidade para
cantar eu quando era criança tem muita
dificuldade tem vários problemas nas
cordas vocais fui pra falar pior porque
ficava roupa tinha fenda calos e uma
série de problemas era um lugar de
muitas emoções e costumava dizer quando
estava sob forte emoção ou ficar
eufórico falando alto ou eu ficava muda
né então eu via que a minha voz
representava um lugar difícil e era ali
que eu queria ir porque eu sabia que ali
eu ia conhecer alguma coisa mais sobre
mim e aí nesse nesse nessa série
eu chamei dois amigos músicos de são
paulo leonardo gorosito alencar martins
ea gente começou arranjar algumas letras
que eu já tinha escrito nesse meu
processo de autoconhecimento de
descobertas e aí nasceu meu primeiro
disco num tom bem confessional no
primeiro disco intitulado cordões
umbilicais era necessidade de incluir as
pessoas ao meu redor na minha criação
artística
chamei minha irmã tivemos uma parceria
juntas numa das canções do disco meu pai
minha mãe cantando no disco que tirei
fotos dos meus
sobrinho recém nascido como como imagem
para o encarte e aí é divulgar na
internet aos poucos ea primeira música
que eu divulguei na internet era música
que eu mas tinha vergonha de cantar e
era exatamente por isso porque eu tenho
mais vergonha eu disse vai ser a
primeira que eu vou colocar
e aí eu coloquei me curar de mim que
dizia assim sua maldade em crise tendo
que reconhecer as fraquezas de um lado
que nem todo mundo ver fiz em uma faxina
e encontrei no meu digo o meu próprio
inimigo que adoece na rotina
eu quero me curar de mim quero me curar
de mim quero me curar de mim
o ser humano é esquisito armadilha de si
mesmo
fala de amor bonito e aponta o enrolei
vim ao mundo em um só corpo é se de um
metro e sessenta leva ele estar atenta
não posso mudar o outro
eu quero me curar de mim quero me curar
de mim quero me curar de mim vou pequena
e pianinho fazer
minhas horas uis eu me rendo da vaidade
que destrói as relações pra mexer do que
importa é preciso me esvaziar minhas
feras encarar a me reconhecer hipócrita
soma sou mentirosa vai dose invejoso sul
mesquinha grão de areia boba e
preconceituoso
sou carente a mostrada do sorriso
socorro conta uma aluna fofoqueira
moralista interesseira e dói dói dói me
expor assim dói dói dói de spicy assim
mas se eu não tiver coragem para
enfrentar os meus defeitos de que forma
de que jeito eu vou me curar de mim se é
que essa cura há de existir
não sei só sei que a busca em mim
só sei que busco me curar de mim
para minha surpresa
ligado pra minha surpresa comecei a
receber mensagens de pessoas de
diferentes religiões por todo o país
agradecendo pela música e um pastor
evangélico entrou em contato comigo
perguntando se podia usar essa música
uma pregação na igreja eu achei super
curioso e disse claro
depois descobri que tinha um grupo que
trabalhava com o líder humanitário será
embalada em são paulo que estava usando
essa música nos retiros de meditação
descobri que tinha um grupo em minas
gerais que também estava usando essa
música nos retiros através do ayahuasca
e aí também grupos de artistas no ceará
no interior de são paulo e gente de todo
o país me mandando mensagens
agradecendo pela música isso foi muito a
rebater a dor pra mim porque é eu vi que
através da ar que estava acessando as
pessoas no lugar um pouco mais profundo
do que eu já tinha vivido até então e
isso passou a fazer muito mais sentido
pra mim quanto artista
a motivação agora não era mas sem ampla
vida nem o deslumbramento ea ilusão que
o palco trás mas sim a conexão de fato
com a minha verdade que automaticamente
vai resolvendo com a verdade das outras
pessoas que buscam uma escuta verdadeira
nesse processo que ainda é muito novo
pra mim eu tirei algumas conclusões
em uma delas é de que encontrei na minha
fragilidade a minha força
descobri que a tristeza e as dores elas
podem ser otimizados porque elas são
verdadeiros antídotos para a hipocrisia
descobri que querem mudar é viver
constantemente no exercício de humildade
porque a gente vive num mundo que se
estimula a competição o individualismo a
vaidade nem tão querer mudar é ir contra
isso diariamente e contra as nossas
próprias sombras né
e percebi que ter consciência
nas nossas sombras é ter liberdade de
escolha para conduzir os pensamentos
para conduzir as relações ao nosso redor
hoje pra mim faz muito mais sentido
pensar no art que tem um caminho a outro
isto é inclusivo e que a idéia daquela
frase sozinho a gente vai mais rápido em
grupo a gente vai mais longe e é esse
longe que hoje me interessa enquanto
artista e acredito que através da arte a
gente pode se em convidar mais pessoas a
repensarem como que tem conduzido as
suas escolhas até aqui pra gente se
despir de fato e todas as máscaras que a
vida vai colocando que a gente vai
absorvendo escola está de fato com que a
gente é de verdade
eu quero me curar de mim quero me curar
e mim quero me curar
henin obrigada